I've been the MP for swanse us for nine
years and long mayor continue Durant
Davies speaking back in 2019 was a labor
MP until today when he was suspended
amid a wave of accusations of
inappropriate sexual behavior
in public he has been an outspoken
advocate for women's rights consent is
consent but in private is it a different
story some of the claims against him go
back decades one former parliamentary
staffer spoke exclusively to Sky News
about her experience she wanted to
remain anonymous so these are her words
read by an actor as a young researcher
in the early 2000s garage made
inappropriate advances towards me
including sexual comments and
inappropriate touching it's a well-known
Secret in Westminster about who to avoid
Mr Davies has also been accused of
boasting about taking sex workers into
Parliament for drinks one labor MP and a
labor peer told Sky News it was well
known that he took them to the commons
bars to show them off
responding to the allegations this
morning the party suspended him and
urged those affected to make formal
complaints the formal complaint has to
be made so the whips can investigate
properly and of course if there has been
any wrongdoing at all then then Swift
action uh uncompromising action has to
be taken during the course of the day a
formal complaint was received a full
investigation was launched but Sky News
has seen evidence that senior labor
Figures were made aware of these
allegations informally many months ago
and political insiders from all parties
tell us these claims were well known
making this the latest example of a
long-standing problem in Westminster
rumors circulating but a reluctance to
address them by those at the top we know
that those stories are out there and
then when it reaches the media I think
that is normally what it takes so why is
it that people at all levels working in
Westminster are still finding it
difficult to come forward and engage
with the the formal processes for the
length of time the lack of time targets
the likelihood that there won't be a
serious punishment and also the limited
options you have and how to make a
complaint mean that it's basically
very restrictive and doesn't lead to
enough people coming forward
Mr Davies Swansea West constituency
office the shutters were down he was
unresponsive to our numerous approaches
for comment but he did say in a
statement to the Politico website I
don't recognize the allegations
suggested and do not know who has made
them none of them as far as I know has
been lodged as complaints with the labor
party or Parliament if I have
inadvertently caused offense to anyone
then I Am Naturally sorry as it is
important that we share an environment
of mutual and equal respect for all
once again the Specter of sexual
misconduct hangs in the air here for
many years there have been calls for
culture change and yet the allegations
keep coming Liz Bates Sky News
Westminster